ever hear your parents talk about a show
they like I was so definitive in its
timeless you're like I want a timeless
show but I don't live in a time where
that [ __ ] happens anymore well good news
if you're watching this video around the
time that I actually uploaded this video
and not 50 years in the future
that means you were alive for a show
like that that makes you mighty
Breaking Bad this series finale spoiler
alert this review is going to have some
spoilers if you haven't watched Breaking
Bad honest to god go watch it so as you
know I'm a huge fan of the show Breaking
Bad and also as you might know Breaking
Bad just wraps series finale it is done
Walter White Heisenberg Jessie all of it
done as if it says bittersweet at this
point I love this show so much was so
cool seeing the decline of Walter White
into villainy the decline is so gradual
yet you do notice it but when you see a
couple of flashbacks where he's just
Walter White with his mustache you know
like episode 1 of season 1 kind of [ __ ]
you're like wow you have fallen far my
friend he's not the same guy at this
point it's just that's so cool for a
group of writers and a whole production
crew and Bryan Cranston one of the best
actors living today so cool they can
bring that to life in a realistic kind
of way you know what I noticed I was
thinking back on season 1 and what I
noticed is when his addiction really
began for me anyway this is what I
noticed some like yeah he's hooked it
was the episode where he was dealing
with Tuco and he made that meth that
wasn't math and it exploded and blew out
his windows and he has that bag and he's
like I dropped this we all die give me
my money
then Tuco does he gets in his car and he
started hitting the steering wheel is
like oh he's really really intense
conject up on adrenaline that was the
high my friends that was the high that
Walter White has been chasing ever since
it hooked him right there he's like this
this is a rush and I'm addicted that's
when his addiction began Breaking Bad is
one of those shows every show you're
like oh it's a great show except that
one season is kind of shitty Breaking
Bad never had a season like that I had a
couple episodes where you're like I
guess that would be filler even the
filler episodes are character
development episodes nothing is
irrelevant in this show and everyone
remember that everyone working on the
shows like didn't know that thing that
happens in season 1 is relevant to
season 5 that's what Eric Draven in The
Crow said he was like that's the thing
about good television nothing is trivial
paraphrasing but I think he meant that
that's also another thing I loved about
the show is it kept me guessing until
the very end I would theorize my friends
and I'd be like oh it's gonna happen
this way or maybe this way and the
show's like no we can write it better
than you it's happening this way and
we're all like yeah yeah that's that's
the best way to go about it my biggest
frustrations with bad television is that
I sit back and like I think I could have
not better all of you Dexter fans feel
that you could have written a better
finale than the one we got don't lie you
do and it's okay to think that because
you could but never in Breaking Bad was
I like I could have done that better
never this show took me to school every
day I was just like I don't know a good
television is on me Breaking Bad it's
just great a great master class [ __ ] I
hate that phrase master class when
people use it like as a master closet
might you need to stop that hipster [ __ ]
breaking bad's in master class no to
hipsters I'm just saying because also
Breaking Bad is grounded in reality
there are some pickles people get into
and you're like oh well this show will
get them out of it sometimes they don't
get out of it because that's just real
also the second half of season five Hank
Schrader his brother-in-law finds out
that Walter white his brother-in-law is
Heisenberg and I was like okay so this
season is going to be him trying to have
really piece together the evidence he's
not going to confront him until the very
end no episode one well episode one of
the second half of season 5 they divided
it into two its season six at that point
but five part two Walter confronts Hank
Hank shuts the garage door just decks
him he's just like Heisenberg's what the
[ __ ] dude one of the greatest lines ever
those Hank's like I don't know who you
are anymore
oh no I'm talking to and while it's just
like if that's true then your best
course might be to tread lightly you're
like who see Hank that's what happens
when you go toe-to-toe with Heisenberg
Walter white died in the room with Gus
fring I have a lot of favorite moments
in the series finale me the directing is
great the camera works awesome there's a
scene when Skyler gets off the phone
with marine and the camera starts
zooming in and behind this little half
wall Walter was just standing there the
entire time that [ __ ] was great my
favorite moment was when he's like
Skyler you have to know that I was doing
this and she stops and she's like if I
have to hear one more time that you did
this for the family he's like no I did
it for myself I was like holy [ __ ] five
seasons six technically five seasons
though of him always saying oh it's for
the families for the family he's like no
it was for me I loved it and I was
really good at it he admitted his ego
it's just awesome I that's great that's
when you know well it's like I know what
I am I admit that I'm an [ __ ] and I
admit it has to end with me
really I can't argue the concept that
Walter did achieve redemption he made
right everything he could make right a
lot of [ __ ] had to go bad a lot of [ __ ]
had to crumble
there's no rebuilding everything for the
cards that he had that he actually dealt
himself he did make right what he could
and that's really all anyone can do in
the situational circumstance that their
ever end I'll be honest with you right
here Breaking Bad is one of the best
dramas ever put on television period I
know some people like way about Game of
Thrones I said one of to leave elastic
room for that kind of [ __ ]
really the only gripes I've ever heard
about Breaking Bad is that it's so hyped
up now everyone's talking about it
everyone's telling their friends to talk
about it everyone's telling their
friends to talk about it and watch it
it's just so big that when someone
finally does watch it for the first time
for the first season and a half maybe a
couple seasons they're like it's kind of
slow and I get that it's all build up
though I will tell everyone what I tell
anyone at a point in season two it will
hook you you will be in it till the end
at that point really that's code for
when Jane chokes on her vomit and Walter
watches it happen
you're in I love Breaking Bad I love
everybody that was in Breaking Bad no
one did a [ __ ] job great job Vince
Gilligan great job writers great job
directors great job Bryan Cranston and
everybody that was ever in Breaking Bad
Aaron Paul to that dude a couple times
was like he almost has me in tears by
the end of this show he is such a broken
human being he's not even looking up at
Walter White he's kind of doing this
you're like they broke him guys messed
up [ __ ] a good job for joking out Todd
man yeah that little Matt Damon looking
creep ass bastard it was so gratifying
scene Jesse just wrapped that chain
around his neck and squeezed the life
out of him that dude was a [ __ ] when
he was dying all I heard was me me he
did a good job there the actor did a
good job that everyone in this show was
really good watch Breaking Bad you will
love Breaking Bad if you think it's love
at the beginning make it through season
two if you're not hooked I guess you're
not gonna get hooked but watch season
three and maybe it'll hook you if not
then season four maybe it'll hook you
not then season five for God's sakes
just watch it because Breaking Bad is
awesome tacular
it's an end of an era my friends I don't
have new episodes of Breaking Bad
anymore that is done and I was there for
it that's awesome
I saw Breaking Bad have you seen it what
did you think about it and the finale
and other shows on AMC what's your
favorite show on AMC right now other
than Breaking Bad I'm really asking for
medicinal purposes I need another show
and AMC is a pretty legit station so
other than Breaking Bad and Walking Dead
what's a good one wherever you thought
of the finale and whatever those shows
would be comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you see here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more